はー。
あー!!
あー、あー
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
学校から帰ってきました。
あのね
あのー
僕は～…。
上手く説明できない。
上手く説明できないんだけれども～
学校があるとね、なかなか時間がなくてね～
ちゃんと動画が撮れないんすよ。
申し訳ないっす。
今日の動画は
手抜き
いや、手抜きでもないな。
ちゃんと、こう趣旨はあるからね
趣旨は、あるんですけれども
あ、でもね、今日はちゃんと言い訳があります。
あの、今日は
学校の授業の宿題をやってから授業に行きました！
素晴らしい！
宿題をやったからね、今日はね、ご勘弁という訳で
今日の動画は
今までの僕がやってきた
ドッキリの総集編でございまーす！
そろそろちゃんとね。
動画の再生リストとかも作って
いろいろ見やすくしたいなと思ってるんですよ！
心霊スポット行ったり、実験系、ドッキリ
よくわかんないのとか
いろいろジャンルがあるんですけども
そういうのをちゃんと分けて
もう、動画何本？！
うわっ！やばいあと少しだ！
もうすぐで動画1000本っすよ
1000本も動画あると
やっぱりこう見たい動画探すの難しいと思うんで
ちょっとずつね！再生リストとか
総集編とか動画も作っていければなと思ってます。
というなの、さぼりです！
いやさぼりじゃないんすよ！
もう、やっぱ宿題をやると時間がないしね
もうすぐテストなんで、がんばりますよ！
はい、というわけで、はじめしゃちょーのドッキリ総集編です！
どうぞ！
（シンバルの音）
ハッハッハ
は）すいません
は）漏らしちゃいました
ト）はっ！
は）うあーー！
ヒ）うぁぁぁー
は）ハハハハハ
ヒ,は）爆笑
バン！（拳銃の音）
うわっ！
バンバンバン！（拳銃の音）
ぶわっ！
うわっ！ははは
シュールストレミング
お客様
朝シャン中なんで(笑)ちょっとまって
髪の毛洗いコーナーのほうへどうぞ！
（爆破の音）
なにやってんの！
うわっ！
うーわ！
うわーーー
うわっ！
（爆破の音）
はぁ
はぁはぁ
ゴホンゴホン
はぁ
はぁはぁ
はぁ、ゴホンゴホン
うわーーうわーー
痛い痛い！
（銅鑼の音）
えっ！！
えっ！！！
えっ！！！！
えっ！！！！！
ははは